let's say that f of x
is equal to x plus 7
to the third power minus 1.
and let's say that g of x
g of x
is equal to the cube root
of
x plus 1
the cube root of x plus 1
minus 7.
now what i want to do now is evaluate
f of
f of g of x
i want to evaluate f of g of x and i
also want to evaluate g of
f of x
g of
f of x and see what i get and i
encourage you like always pause the
video and and try it out
all right let's first evaluate f of g of
x so that means g of x this expression
is going to be our input so everywhere
we see an x in the definition for f of x
we would replace it with all of g of x
so f of g of x is going to be equal to
so it's going to be equal to well i see
an x right over there so i'd write all
of g of x there so that's the cube root
of
x plus 1
minus 7
and then i have plus 7
plus
7 to the 3rd power minus 1. notice
wherever i saw the x since i'm taking f
of g of x i replace it with what g of x
is and so that is the cube root of x
plus 1 minus 7. all right i'll see if we
can simplify this well we have a minus 7
plus 7 so that simplifies nicely so this
just becomes this is equal to i can do a
neutral color now this is equal to
the cube root of
x plus 1
to the third power minus one
well if i take the cube root of x plus
one and then i raise it to the third
power well that's just going to give me
x plus one
so
this part
this part just simplifies to x plus one
and then i subtract 1
so it all simplified out to just being
equal to x
so we're just left with an x so f of g
of x is just x
so now let's try what g of f of x is
so g of f of x is going to be equal to
i'll do it right over here
this is going to be equal to
the cube
root
of
and actually i could let me write it out
wherever i see an x i can write f x
instead i didn't do it that last time i
went directly and replaced with the
definition of f of x but just to make it
clear what i'm doing so everywhere i'm
seeing an x i replace it with an f of x
so the cube root of f of x
plus 1
minus 7.
well that's going to be equal to the
cube root of
cube root of f of x
which is all of this business over here
so that is x plus
7
to the third power
minus 1 and then we add 1
and we add 1 and then we subtract the 7.
lucky for us this subtracting 1 and
adding 1 those cancel out and so we're
going to take the cube root of x plus 7
to the third power well the cube root of
x plus 7 to the third power is just
going to be x plus 7.
so this is going to be
x plus seven so all of this business
simplifies to x plus seven and then we
need to subtract seven
and these two cancel out or they negate
each other and we are just left with x
so we see something very interesting f
of g of x is just x and g of f of x is x
so if we in this case if we start with
an x
if we start with an x we input it into
the function g
and we get g of x
we get g of x
and then we input that into the function
f
and we put that into the function f
f of g of x gets us back to x
it gets us back to x so we kind of did a
round trip and the same thing is
happening over here if i put x
into
f of x
if i put x into f or sorry if i get put
x into the function f and i get f of x
the output is f of x and then i input
that into g into the function g
into the function g once again i do this
round trip and i get back to x
another way to think about it another
way to think about it if you view this
as so this is these are these are both
composite functions but one way to think
about it is if these are the set of all
possible inputs into either of these
composite functions
and then these are the outputs
so you are starting with an x
you are starting with an x i'll do this
case first so g is a mapping let me let
me write down
so g is going to be a mapping from x
to
g of x so this is what g is doing
so the function g maps from x to
some value g of x
g of x and then if you were to apply f
to this value right over here if you
apply f to this value to g of x
you get all the way back to x
so that is f of
g of x
and vice versa if you go the if you
start with x and you apply f of x first
so if you start with f if you apply f of
x first let me do that
so if you apply f of x first you say you
get to this value so that is
f of x
so you applied the function f but you
apply the function g to that
you apply the function g to that
you get back so this is g of
g of f of x
i should say g of
or g of f we're we're applying the
function g to the value f of x and so
since we get a round trip either way we
know that the functions g and f are
inverses of each other in fact we can
write
we can write that f of x
is equal to the inverse of g of x
inverse of g of x and vice versa g of x
is equal to the inverse of f of x
inverse
of
f of x
hope you enjoyed that